the joggin experience now as this
expands us fight for the Forgotten
expands and you do more and more work in
the Congo do you anticipate moving to
other parts of the world yeah so we
already in Uganda right we started that
last year but we really kick-started at
April with this big kind of celebration
on new land five acres because of
Dustin's donation we're gonna take that
up to 30 more acre so 35 acres in Uganda
we want to get that to a hundred we want
to get it to even more than that there's
a potential that with fight for the
Forgotten we could potentially start up
a social enterprise or what are those
called be corpse or something like that
where it's a social entrepreneurship gig
where we start up maybe a coffee farm
maybe a honey farm in these mountainous
regions and the pygmies can have a
sustainable job they love coffee and
honey those are two things that they
love coffee and coffee and honey it's
funny there's this but John G as a pygmy
man grandfather an elder in baba Kulu
village but John G he's actually in the
in the book a picture with my wife
leaning over and she's squatting down
and she's still as tall as he is and
she's in a full squat and she hidden so
he's a really little guy but this one
time I saw him his grandkids had just
raided a honey hive or bee hive and they
just had honey all over their hands
their arms their faces I look like I'm
getting stung no they get stung get
stung like crazy yeah they start a fire
at the bottom and then they throw a vine
around it and then they just walked up
it with your feet and you're holding
onto the vines on Jesus and it's crazy
you take an ax up there and then you
just start hacking into the tree with
Africanized calling home which are
killer beasts which is nuts
so there's killer from killer bees or
gangster
they're quick they're cruel my house is
stealing honey from killer oh my god
and someone else everyone else is
freaked out by it how many things do
they get hundreds
hundreds but it's worth it to him so
they start that fire underneath and the
smoke goes up so that helps keep them
off then if two people climb up it the
sole person's job on the back is to have
these Leafs from a twig and they just
are hitting the bees off of the guy
raiding the hive do you remember when
everybody was worried that Africanized
killer bees were gonna come over here
and kill us all yes that was like a big
fear like 20 years ago how the killer
bees they've been spotted in New Mexico
whoa they came up from but then they
buried it right and and without him see
bees right I think this yeah we don't
have to worry about those are bees when
they went down the Amazon and came up
here those would be dangerous yeah so
these guys they do this they and honey
they they catch it in a bag or something
like how do they they put it in a basket
a basket the basket handle in India some
guys doing pretty much the same exact
thing those are the killer bees yeah
those are different piece but the same
strategy same strategy have you could
reach in and grab bees this guy's an
[ __ ] what are you doing man have you
guys seen that there's a certain type of
honey that has some sort of psychedelic
effect and it's a very popular honey I
want to say Nepal somewhere is it Nepal
yeah
and these guys they climb up to get this
[ __ ] it's like on the side of cliffs
like see you have anything else and yeah
see these guys use these ropes to climb
up to get that rope looks sketchy as
[ __ ] that looks like some homemade [ __ ]
right there
and so they this honey hunting work is
very mean it's the craziest thing I've
seen people do but these guys this is a
hundred two hundred feet in the air man
this is a different kind of honey for
some reason this honey makes you trip
balls of course it's a vice documentary
yeah the Nepalese honey that makes
people hallucinate so they add something
into it no no no no no it has to do with
whatever these plants these guys are
holding the pollens are yeah so they're
making a psychedelic honey just
naturally yes
nacho so you
thousand UT and meet Jesus that seems
dangerous I'm so and maybe maybe it's
like a mild micro dosing type oh that's
true I don't know so yeah so like that
that's what they just grabbed it and
Eden honeycombs DeLozier Center yeah so
these kids I think there's a video on my
youtube changing and find out of these
kids climbing these trees I think it's
just Justin ran fight for the Forgotten
is the YouTube channel and there's this
kid that I put a GoPro on his head
because he was just climbing trees like
crazy up to the canopy of the rainforest
he's like nine years old oh my god times
two hundred feet me hair and he looks
down at us
it's a 12-minute video or something but
we could fast forward this is any kind
of safety harness right no he's
literally just doing a shimmying up it
he doesn't even have a bone he's doing
it with his arms in his thighs he's nine
he's just my daughter scaling it just
scaling and he looks down on us I can
barely see him in the tree still he's
like over 200 feet tall and and what's
he getting up there will he practice for
two different things he had his bow and
arrow up there so he could shoot nest
and shoot birds out a nest in the trees
from 200 feet up tuna feet up but he's
shooting to other trees oh my god and
then they that's how they collect honey
look at them this is a little guy
this is him going from a little tree to
getting over to a huge tree next to it
but that's him but Buffy and I lived
there for three months I think in this
village and he's seriously just scaling
the tree yeah it's a 12-minute video
what it's wild if we can't have sound
it's just him breathing hi this guy is
not even sweating and he just keeps
going until he gets and once he gets to
the big part of the tree I should go
back up up back a little bit more
because he starts just zooming down he
gets to the top and looks down at us and
whenever you see us I think this is
where it is maybe
when whenever he looks down look at that
oh hi oh boy and that's not even when he
was at the very top and he's just using
his hands and feet yeah he literally has
no rope no vine so she was like you
should be under him to catch him yeah
but no from 200 feet up it would just
break your arms yeah that's like
[Applause]